for a look at the media's role in sort
of setting up this whole
framing of the trump raid we turn to fox
news contributor raymond arroyo raymond
you've been
watching this play out this evening
and you notice kind of a choreography
surrounding this story what is it indeed
laura look it happened over the weekend
on cnn both sunday and this morning new
york times reporter maggie haberman was
out flogging a story that she's covered
before the allegation that president
trump flushed documents down a toilet
she came armed with pictures this time
supposedly from a source just in time to
promote her new book
haberman may well be the john the
baptist on this raid story watch this
laura gross and important i think are
the two important words here people are
going to make all kinds of jokes about
toilets and so forth it would still be a
story if it was a fireplace and the
point is about the destruction of
records which are supposed to be
preserved under the presidential records
act which is a watergate era
creation
how curious laura two days she went out
flogging this story the timing of this
and the leaked pictures to haberman
making the rounds
it all does seem rather coordinated
predictable and as she said gross and
important indeed well she said tonight
on another network that you know
no one knows where this is all going to
go
uh and they've tried to get trump before
and they they impeached him twice and he
i'm paraphrasing but essentially the
undercurrent was he emerges
um i know but stronger that's not the
point the point is as we've seen in the
recent past journalists are often used
to trot information into the public
domain and then that becomes the
predicate for federal action we saw that
with michael isikoff who was at yahoo
news he was the guy who carried the
steele dossier into the public domain
that became the justification for
federal investigations and subpoenas and
on it went until they admitted there was
nothing there now earlier tonight dana
bash said that president trump was
trying to own the narrative laura on
this raid but i don't know why she
didn't say the media is also trying to
own the narrative
in between celebrating
the idea that they would raid the home
of a former president and search the
home of a former president uh is uh
obviously as big as biggest stakes as
you can have for the fbi to actually be
knocking down doors in his home is this
a time that americans can believe that
perhaps the orange jumpsuit is for is
forthcoming i think the national
democratic reaction is hallelujah now
whether that bears out or that continues
on we'll see this has been a slow road
but it's a road that will hopefully
strengthen our american democracy which
has been uh very fragile these last few
years and post trump presidency
the narrative is so plain laura i mean
and if you listen to it all as i have
been all evening here's the upshot the
democratic party finds itself in a
difficult spot with gas prices
international worries and inflation uh
eating away at their uh minor or my
bare majority going into these midterms
they've decided there's only one
strategy that will work we have to draft
donald trump to run against so
this whole moment is now choreographed
at the at this time before the midterms
to drag trump front and center and to
use him as the whipping boy while they
cast themselves as you heard it there
the agents and protectors of democracy
yeah it's
it's a screwed up strategy i mean i i'm
going to say this again
if they wanted
to unite the republican party if that
was their goal they're doing a great job
of it like i think they thought that liz
cheney was somehow like aligning
themselves with her on that january 6
committee was going to somehow like
separate the party i mean there's the
old establishment but most republicans
just want trump's policies back even if
they don't like trump that much they
loved his policies and they want that
type of republican
in the white house whether it's trump or
whether it's someone else they don't
want the old establishment that is over
those people are part of the problem
here because every time raymond they get
into power they play games like we got
to preserve the filibuster so we're
going to give the republicans the
infrastruc the democrats the
infrastructure bill
so
that that playing the the sweet little
old rules that's got to go meat was
right about that you have stark policy
differences that are at play here you
had the american first trumpism and now
you see joe biden's agenda and americans
will have to decide that ultimately and
get past all the rest of these theatrics
but remember haberman called this moment
gross and important well tonight
historian michael beschloss used two
other descriptors listen
let's pause for a second to look at how
weird and horrible this is i take your
description of what happened today weird
and horrible and imagine that one day my
two daughters will read a history book
where today goes down as weird and
horrible tomorrow is the day when you're
going to want to buy the physical copy
of the newspaper
you're going to want to buy it and fold
it carefully maybe put it in a little
archival paper or parchment if you don't
have that
laura that is an amazing moment to hear
rachel maddow the pied piper of the
entire russian conspiracy narrative this
conspiracy theory that fell apart she
never apologized for it by the way i
think she called uh
isakoff at one time who was trying to
apologize for it she called him weird or
something on her ear and kind of called
him out this is an amazing moment when
you have partisanship masquerading not
only as journalism but as history people
have to see through this and i know it's
it's hard to do so with these voices
screaming
no no but what everyone has to
understand
is that everything we've heard
about the republicans are now if they
don't dump trump then they're clearly
want to destroy democracy and they're
going to be the wrecking balls to our
entire constitutional system
this is from the same people who want to
pack the court who want to get rid of
the electoral college uh you know who
who want to now use government to in
weaponize it against the american people
whether this you know irs praetorian
guard or or now search warrants and
surveillance and subpoenas
so these are the people who are
constantly ripping at the fabric of our
founders tearing down statues
celebrating police precincts being
burned in minnesota and
and the republicans and the
conservatives are the trouble this is
ridiculous well not only is it
ridiculous laura to use their
phraseology now i guess we have to put
two adjectives together it's ridiculous
and distressing in that while we are
covering this raid and trying to figure
out what's at play here it provides a
convenient distraction from what you
probably didn't see by design the
current president of the united states
visiting kentucky flood victims after
his covet hibernation he was totally in
charge today laura can you all hear me
as this on
we don't know that the rest y'all
everybody else should be doing this
i said what are you you're kidding me
not seriously what are they talking
about it's not like it's beyond our
control
the weather may be out of control for
now but it's not beyond our control what
we're doing today we passed yesterday
helping taking care of everything from
health care to god knows what else he is
the head of emergency management in
kentucky
and i gotta say he and his team
have been doing an incredible job
i i bet the governor there was hoping
he'd do an incredible job masking with
all the coughing i mean the man just got
out of covert quarantine now he's
coughing all over everybody but laura
you want to know why this is timed out
for this moment it's because of that
moment and i think everybody needs to
take a hard look at it well raymond come
on it only took about i don't know 45
seconds for him to get his jacket on as
he came off the plane that was enough
i thought it was perfecting a comedy
routine for a minute there laura maybe
we'll show people that later jill jill
did have a candy striper dress on that
was a blue it almost looked like she was
the candy striper and they are very
helpful to the infirm and they
it was quite yeah
that this isn't the moment though but it
was that it was they had the jacket on
there yeah and he was struggling to get
the jacket on and it he went in a circle
it was really it was really quite comic
i will show it to you later it's worth
seeing well raymond the division here
should not be overlooked i think that
again this is a time for people who love
our country
love our representative democracy uh
respect our constitution
to take a breath
realize we've been through worse than
this before
and we will get this through this again
but when we get power back it's time to
hold everyone accountable the military
leadership the civilian leadership the
civil surface those in congress who've
abused their power all of them have to
be held accountable all of them it can't
be this nice guy routine so let's be
friends just must be blind and and those
who are reporting have to do so with as
much truth as possible as well and not
from an ideological perspective all
right raymond thank you very thank you
very much hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else